romain miguet ce bonjour merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
alors on vient de me voir les autorités
de caracas sont graciés une centaine
d'opposants et para milieu il ya des
députés des collaborateurs également de
juan garrido
comment est-ce que vous analysez ce
geste de nicolás maduro
bonjour alors c'est que cette amnistie
intervient au moment où l'opposition est
extrêmement fragmenté vous avez pour
ainsi dire deux camps l'un qui est là la
ligne radicale qui est mise en place par
les états unis et qui représentait par
monsieur points de bordeaux et l'autre
qui compte un nombre très important
aujourd'hui
dowd opposants membres des principaux
partis compris qu'ils soutenaient mme
gouardo
donc ils s'écharpent on va dire sur le
fait s'il faut participer ou non aux
élections donc monsieur juan gouaille de
ne veut pas donc savons mais il ya un
nombre très important d'opposants qui
veulent participer aux élections
législatives et puis il sèchera aussi
sur les sanctions et notamment les
dernières sanctions des etats-unis sur
le diesel je rappelle qu'il ya quinze
jours
les etats-unis ont arraisonné en haute
mer 5 tankers pétroliers qui était
chargé de diesel à destination du
venezuela et ont tout simplement volé la
cargaison
or le diesel c'est des transports privés
et collectifs c'est aussi l'électricité
au venezuela dans les thermoélectriques
c'est le transport des aliments et donc
il ya un nombre considérable de
dirigeants de l'opposition qui voit bien
que cette politique est complètement
anti populaires je me permets de vous
interrompre ce selon vous pourquoi avoir
annoncé cette décision aujourd'hui est
ce qu'on peut parler d' un pas en
direction d'un apaisement des tensions
finalement oui c'est pour ça que je me
permettais de de rappeler cette cette
fragmentation de l'opposition puisque en
vue des élections parlementaires du 6
décembre monsieur maduro a donné des
gages à l'opposition et aussi à la
minorité de pays qui ne soutiennent pas
l'option électorale comme sortie de
crise je rappelle qu' il y à un nouveau
centre national électoral dans certains
vecteurs sont ouvertement d'opposition
et puis cette amnistie dans le but
de réconcilier le pays d'unir le pays et
de trouver une option électorale comme
sortie possible de la crise politique
qui touche le venezuela depuis
maintenant plusieurs mois voire années
justement selon vous est ce qu'on peut
s'attendre finalement à d'autres signes
d'apaisement dans les prochains jours
les prochaines semaines vers où on va
aveyron dirige finalement écouté c'est
vraiment le une tentative pour remettre
l'opposition sur le chemin
constitutionnel et démocratique
enfin je pense qu'il ne faut pas mettre
de côté aussi qu accepté l'amnistié
présidentielle c'est aussi reconnaître
le président nicholas maduro comme
légitime et cela place aussi l'union
européenne et les gouvernements des
territoires qui la composent devant
leurs contradictions puisqu'il avait
fait de la libération de certains
politiciens prisonniers ou en fuite eut
un préambule nécessaire à la
reconnaissance des prochaines élections
parlementaires donc nicolás maduro knees
absolument sûr un grand consensus au
sein d'une partie de l'opposition et
évidemment des chavistes pour la
reconnaissance électorale que le peuple
vénézuélien puisse décider en paix et de
manière démocratique du futur du
venezuela
très bien merci infiniment pour toutes
ces précisions un romain légumes je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste du venezuela merci à vous